getting home for the Christmas holiday
may prove to be a nightmare for some
Travelers record cold temperatures are
on the way followed by blizzard-like
conditions later in the week from the
Midwest to the Northeast Airlines want
travelers to consider re-booking holiday
travel ahead of the severe weather
United American and Southwest Airlines
have all posted travel waivers for those
flying to from or through many U.S
airports but Travel Experts stress that
the time to take advantage of those
waivers is right now
if you wait till flights start being
canceled it's too late
a lot of flights are going to be
canceled and you may be stranded waivers
typically allow passengers to rebook
without change fees or Fair increases
now you can check your air carriers
website for details this is going to be
a bitterly cold blast across much of the
country later in the week Heather yeah
tough timing Sherry thank you if you are
headed out to Reed International this
week some useful travel tips here for
you just make sure to give yourself more
time than you think you might actually
need because those parking garages and
the Lots they fill up they reach
capacity and when it comes to gifts you
know you've probably heard this it's
recommended to not wrap them and finally
with delays and cancellations being a
big issue make sure you have anything
that's really important like medications
with you just in case your flight is
changed